y
[Música]
pero yo tiene un cuarto gabinete y los
seis meses del mandato de pedro castillo
en total siete cargos fueron
reemplazados y polémica por el
nombramiento de aníbal torres antiguo
ministro de justicia y derechos humanos
como presidente del consejo de ministros
analizamos en esta emisión
inició en la ciudad francesa de presta
la one options hamid una cumbre que
busca reforzar la protección de los
océanos en la que uno de los principales
ejes era la lucha contra la pesca ilegal
y los plásticos
la corte internacional de justicia
dictaminó que uganda tendrá que pagar
325 millones de dólares como
compensación a la república democrática
del congo por las masacres y los daños
materiales registrados cuando invadió
parte de ese país durante la segunda
guerra del congo entre 1998 y 2003
quinchas ha reclamado a más de 11 mil
millones en compensaciones
buenas tardes para todos bienvenidos a
esta emisión de noticias en france 24
soy valentina torre sánchez damos inicio
en perú donde el presidente pedro
castillo presento a su cuarto gabinete
en los seis meses de mandato que ha
tenido el jefe de estado hizo siete
cambios en total entre ellos el jefe del
consejo de ministros cargo que ahora
será ocupado por aníbal torres antiguo
ministro de justicia y derechos humanos
tras la juramentación diputados de la
oposición indicaron que castillo
incumplió su promesa de nombrar un
gabinete más participativo un legislador
del partido derechista podemos perú
calificó a torres de errático
confrontacional y resentido para
analizar esta información conectamos con
omar cairo roldán él es abogado
constitucionalista y profesor de derecho
constitucional en la pontificia
universidad católica de perú bienvenido
a france 24 porque la figura de aníbal
torres causa tanta polémica
bueno en realidad creo que el problema
de este gabinete no es tanto el
nombramiento de aníbal torres sino a
quien se pudo haber nombrado y no se
nombró y se sacó del gabinete y me
refiero al ministro de salud
el señor zevallos que a
ha sido el único éxito indiscutible que
ha tenido este gobierno hasta este
momento que es la vacunación
más de 20 millones de peruanos tienen
dos vacunas y por lo tanto están
protección contra una muerte por éste
por este virus y este es el ministerio
se iba a ser el primer ministro pero
trascendió que como de conformidad con
la constitución al primer ministro le
corresponde proponer lo siguiente a los
demás ministros el presidente no habría
aceptado estas propuestas y pretendía
nombrar ministros de su preferencia
entonces el perú ahora tiene al
ministro al primer ministro vázquez y
además ha prescindido de él el director
de esta gestión exitosa en materia de
salud y la polémica se refiere bueno
porque hay una especie de lenguaje
estridente que emplea veces el ministro
torres pero creo que existe la anécdota
para mí lo más importante es que el perú
el gobierno ha prescindido del ministro
que estaba llevando gestión del problema
más importante del país y de muchos
países en este momento que es el hombre
también enfrentamiento de la pandemia en
su reemplazo se ha nombrado aún aún a
una persona que tiene en investigaciones
por corrupción y además el señalamiento
de
promover bebidas este pseudo científicas
entonces este el problema creo que es es
mucho más grave que el temperamento del
señor torres viene desde su perspectiva
este cuarto gabinete traerá estabilidad
para el gobierno del castillo
ojalá ojalá la inestabilidad tiene como
tiene como raíz el hecho de que
generalmente cuando se programa un
presidente y si éste juramenta y un mes
de distancia y ahí se preparan los dos
los equipos en este caso no pasó así
porque
la oposición el partido perdedor demoró
en reconocer los resultados impugnó y
sólo pudo ser proclamado el presente
castillo días antes de juramentar esa es
la razón por la cual no tuvo equipo
parado
presentó un gabinete que fue
improvisado y el primero así como los
otros tres y este es que esperamos
esperemos que no sea que no ocurre lo
mismo y que de alguna está bien
estabilidad lo preocupante es creo el
sector salud señor omar cayeron roldán a
ustedes gracias por su análisis y por
compartirlo en france24 en otras
noticias el enviado especial de eeuu
para el clima john kerry llegó a méxico
para reunirse con el presidente andrés
manuel lópez obrador el funcionario
aseguró que washington quiere trabajar
con méxico para promover energías
renovables en américa del norte en
octubre pasado lópez obrador presenta un
proyecto de ley que según eeuu promueve
el uso de tecnologías más sucias
anticuadas y costosas en lugar de
alternativas renovables eficientes lo
que pondría en desventaja a los
consumidores ya la economía en general
kerry aseguró que la administración de
job aid en está lista para acompañar a
méxico a aumentar sus vehículos
eléctricos y energía renovable
en francia inició la one options omiten
la ciudad portuaria de brest decenas de
países junto con científicos y grupos
ecologistas participarán en la cumbre
durante tres días con el objetivo de
reforzar la protección de los océanos y
sus ecosistemas
contaminación sobrepesca destrucción de
hábitats calentamiento de aguas los
problemas que enfrenta el océano son
muchos y en francia los asistentes de la
one ocean summer esperan abordarlos la
restauración del océano de lo que está
en juego los océanos están en mal estado
no necesitan pero sobre todo nosotros
los necesitamos los necesitamos porque
son una fuente de oxígeno porque son un
sumidero de carbono los océanos cubren
el 70% de nuestro planeta producen la
mitad del oxígeno del mundo absorben el
dióxido de carbono desempeñando un papel
crucial en la regulación del clima y son
el hogar de millones de especies pero
también tienen una importancia económica
y geopolítica decisiva la pesca es una
industria mundial de 400 mil millones de
dólares y el 90% de las mercancías
comercializadas se transportan por vía
marítima además aproximadamente un
tercio del petróleo mundial se produce
en alta mar y también en las empresas
mineras muestran un creciente interés
por la exploración en aguas profundas
de minerales actividades humanas que
están llevando a los océanos al límite y
por las que los activistas piden más
regulación y protección y esperan que la
cumbre lo consiga
queremos ver compromisos concretos
actualmente sólo el 3 por ciento de los
hábitats marinos del mundo están
protegidos pero los científicos
recomiendan que protejamos el 30 por
ciento de los hábitats marinos para
seguir obteniendo beneficios sostenibles
de estos ecosistemas de beneficio físico
y sistema los conservacionistas esperan
que la cumbre dé un nuevo impulso a los
esfuerzos por finalizar un tratado
jurídicamente vinculante que proteja las
aguas internacionales en marzo empezará
una nueva ronda de conversaciones de la
onu que tendrá como objetivo concluir
este acuerdo continúa en parís el juicio
contra los responsables de los atentados
del 13 de noviembre de 2015 que dejaron
130 muertos y cientos de heridos ante el
tribunal de lo criminal de la capital
francesa el principal acusado y único
sobreviviente de los comandos yihadistas
sala de slam aseguro que no mató ni
hirió a nadie por lo que considera
injusto que la fiscalía busque darle
cadena perpetua admitió que apoya al
estado islámico pero resaltó que se le
está juzgando de forma calumnioso para
intentar dar ejemplo
hace 24 años uganda invadió la república
democrática del congo siendo ésta la
segunda guerra del congo en donde
cientos de miles de personas murieron
quizás ha reclamado más de 11.000
millones de dólares en reparaciones pero
este miércoles la corte internacional de
justicia ordenó que ogando a pague la
suma de 325 millones de dólares a su
vecino por las masacres y los daños
registrados entre 1998 y 2003
el monto de las reparaciones reclamadas
por la república democrática del congo
uganda ante la corte internacional de
justicia corresponde a la evaluación de
los daños hacia los bienes y las
personas durante la segunda guerra del
congo entre 1998 y 2003 kinshasa afirma
que 400.000 civiles perdieron la vida
como consecuencia de la ocupación y que
600.000 personas han sido desplazadas
también se incluyen en esta cantidad las
reparaciones por daños a la propiedad
incluyendo el saqueo de los recursos la
explotación de los bosques y la
destrucción de los parques naturales
en 2005 la corte internacional de
justicia órgano judicial de la onu
encargado de resolver los edificios
entre estados dictaminó que uganda debía
pagar una indemnización a la república
democrática del congo entonces los dos
países tuvieron que negociar el monto de
la factura
desde el inicio del procedimiento uganda
refuta la cantidad calculada por
kinshasa argumentando que uganda no era
el único país involucrado en la guerra y
que la factura es demasiado altas la
falta de conciliación entre los dos
países hizo que el proceso se alargará
las cosas se extendieron hasta que en
2021 las dos partes presentaron por fin
sus reclamaciones al tribunal para que
el arbitraje sea definitivo con esta
información llegamos al final de la
emisión pero los invitamos a continuar
con nosotros que volvemos en breve
[Música]